make art now yeah not just your channel
but the concept of that is that
something you wish you had
adopted earlier in your life uh
make art now is more of instructions
there are instructions for you guys
so if you i mean
the the truth is that make art now came
out of trump being elected
yeah i mean we were all kind of
dumbfounded looking at each other
and uh i was like what do i do now
and my buddy looked at me he's like make
art now and i was like that's it that's
that's exactly what we should do and i
feel like
the world kind of collectively is going
through a stage whether it's whether
you're for trump or not
you can definitely see that there's a
lot of change going on there's a lot of
people that are unhappy there's a lot of
countries that are
rioting and protesting and just going
through a lot of
systemic change and i don't know i look
at that like the renaissance period of
like all the birth of all this crazy
amazing art
and how much pain and suffering that
took for that to be triggered and so
make art now was yeah it was out of the
trump thing but
it also was uh
instructions for for people to just go
out and do it
you know and i'm sure as a youtuber you
can see the change in the comments as
well
there's angrier comments sometimes maybe
you know i actually i have a pretty
i'm pretty lucky uh my channel does not
receive a ton of hate
comments i've weeded out a lot of those
types of people i guess
they're just not really into my stuff or
maybe they see how hard
how hard i work at the video so it's
kind of like
they appreciate the the time and effort
put in there and so they're
a little bit more lenient but i think i
got off easy actually
most people they get some really bad
comments um
just a lot of angry people that are
upset at the world and i feel like
if i were to compare channels i get off
pretty easy compared to other channels
yeah you initially wanted to be a
screenwriter
yeah i initially went to college in
arizona and uh studied screenwriting
read all the books uh wrote a couple of
screenplays never had anything made
and then came out to los angeles took
uh some ucla extension courses on
screenwriting
and i was like
at somehow i think i tricked myself into
saying that i was going to be an
actor and so i went full on
into the whole actor world and doing the
you know nine to five waiting tables and
then
um going to auditions when i could or or
classes
at night and you know
scene study and paying for coaches and
all that kind of thing
it was all under the illusion of
storytelling
of like i wanted to just create
and so i spent 10 years doing that and
and then realized
that i didn't need to nail it as an
actor
in order for me to go back to
storytelling i could just
story tell so it's kind of full circle
started out as screenwriting
then into acting and then into youtube
and now it's like a blend it's a
mishmash of
everything together so this is a
personal question you don't have to
answer but
did you ever make more acting than you
did at the waiting tables job i know you
can make a lot waiting tables so no
no i mean my experience act
i'll tell you the thing that kind of
made me turn the
tables on whether or not i wanted to
continue pursuing acting at this point i
was 10 years
down the rabbit hole and so i'm just
throwing good money after bad and i
haven't had that much
success i've been a couple short films
been in a couple movies
been on a tv show in terms of like how
much
money and time and effort that i spent
going
head first into this really challenging
and competitive career field
there was not a lot of feedback that was
telling me to keep going
and i think the straw that broke the
camel's back was uh we ended up
producing our own film we wrote
we shot it we edited it we produced it
with a couple of other actor friends of
ours
and it was the most extensive amount of
time that i'd spent acting
actually perfecting my craft and
actually performing
when i'm not in class or you know doing
like
little plays or whatever in
hollywood it was the most amount of time
that i actually
was doing the thing that i wanted to do
not just
practicing to do it or the auditioning
thing and
that just broke my heart i was like wow
the i have spent so much money and time
and effort and just willpower trying to
do this thing that
like it's not responding to me at all
and it's been 10 years
and the most experience that i have is
something that i produce myself
like something's something's just not
working and then it just clicked i was
i was done and it was it felt like a
really long breakup
and i was like oh my god now i'm free
the shackles have been removed i
i can go do whatever it is that i want
to do i don't have to be an actor i
don't have to
do interviews and and try to sell movies
and i mean that's not even the thing
audition i didn't have to audition
anymore right
i didn't have to prove myself to go be
in a role i could just
go create the role and you were working
as a waiter
at the time yeah so i spent about uh
five years at one restaurant and another
three years and another one
and so i'd been in the restaurant
industry for about 10 years
you know waiting for that that role to
come around or that producer
or that director i mean the whole that
whole stereotype is so true
i mean you literally are waiting on
other people
to live your life for you and i just got
tired of it
is someone in your family an
entrepreneur they have a business
yeah i have an uncle who's an
entrepreneur he started doing ebay sales
back in the ebay
just started up and then that bloomed
into
like uh a really profitable company that
he still is running
uh so that i got my first start actually
my very first job was
doing shipping and receiving at his
company doing that when i was like 16.
so everyone else is partying i was doing
that
um but that was like
that was that was high school yeah and
that's pretty much the only entrepreneur
in the family
uh yeah so you saw the amount of time
and effort and
late nights or whatever and you know
something breaks and it's on him to fix
it and
you saw that and did you are you trying
to link with like my handy skills or
whatever
both and also having the channel and and
all of the time and effort and
i think i think the work ethic i got
from my uncle and seeing just how much
he i saw the freedom how the price of
his freedom
was he was working for the studios
before
and he was making great money but he had
no time he had no freedom he would make
all his money working overtime hours
and then he finally had a breaking point
and he was like i can't do it anymore i
would rather
make far less money doing the things
that i want to do having a sense of
autonomy and freedom
and take a significant pay cut and so i
think i got
that work mentality from him which is
just
as long as you're doing what you want to
do maybe it's worth it and for me that's
definitely ranked true i much rather
have my own autonomy and freedom
but in terms of like the handiness i've
i
hate to bring up burning man in this
publication
but all of my handiness in terms of
working with my hands
ingenuity creating things that is 100
percent
uh comes from going to burning man
seeing
other people like me who are not
electricians who are not carpenters
and yet they built something incredible
they
put themselves under a deadline they
raised money they made promises they
said that they were going to do
something and then they actually carried
it out and at the end of that project
they came away with a ton of skills
things that they normally would not have
had the chance to do in their normal
day-to-day life
so uh that going to eight burning mans
in a row has somehow drilled into my
head
you know the self autonomy the
uh what's the theme of burning man sasha
sasha here
uh what's it called uh self
the self self-reliance yeah
when did you decide to start your
channel i started the channel
january of 2018
but i had been thinking about it for
about a year before
um it was something that i knew that i
wanted to do
um it started out really i just wanted
to
like i wanted to show reel so that i
could get more work
and then i realized you have far more
work if you have your personality
blended in there you know if people
really get a sense of knowing you
they're going to hire you if they
trust you if they know your sense of
humor if they know that
if the pressure is on you're not gonna
crack you're not gonna blow your lid
you're not gonna embarrass them in front
of clients
you're gonna you're gonna like just
figure it out and get the job done
they're gonna hire you nine times out of
ten you don't have to be
the best you don't have to have the best
show reel and so
uh i looked at a youtube channel as a
way to like infuse
my work some cinematography storytelling
ability
my need to somehow like validate all the
years of acting
and so like building these like imagine
like borderline fiction but
somehow grounded in truth documentary
style vlogs
um and blend the personality in there
and
so that's what i that's what the
intention was all along
and now it's like two years into it i
kind of feel like
i'm not so much shooting in the dark now
i kind of understand what i'm doing
but if it it didn't start out that way
but that was the intention for sure what
was the first video that you made
uh the first video i did
was i think it was like five
camera hacks or something for traveling
filmmakers it was
it was supposed to be short and kind of
be
like a shot out of the canon of all
these things that you probably didn't
know you could do
like make your own media pass so you can
get discounts when you fly airlines
but it it feels a little foreign now
when i think about like what
i want with my channel it just feels
like it's a little out of place
and how much time did you spend editing
that one
first video oh god that first video
uh i actually shot it twice so i had
worked on that video
when i very first started the channel um
it was a year in the making so that
first video took me a year
to just get the nerve to figure it out
to shoot it
figure out what i wanted to say i shot
it i edited it
and then i sat on it for a couple of
months and then
about a year later i looked at it and i
was like this is crap and i re-shot it
again
and re-edited it so it was completely
new
and that was my first episode and
actually i think it was
that episode was not five camera hacks
um that story that you're talking about
is from i think it was like episode two
or three
it was uh building a youtube studio out
of my bedroom
yeah so that one
the funny thing is that my cousin
watched both versions and he couldn't
tell the difference so it was
like and i totally agree with him now
it's it's so ridiculous
uh having to reshoot and edit i mean
even though it's like
it's the same content it's the same
message it's the same the same talking
points you know just but shooting it a
little cleaner
what are your thoughts on having a
perfect video versus just getting
content out there
you know i i don't know that i would
recommend
anyone do what i'm doing because
i go against the grain so everyone it's
like known rule of thumb that
you just pump out as much content as you
can you build that audience and you just
keep
repeating what is successful and you do
it as fast as you can
because you want to build that momentum
and for me i want to look back at 10
years
and look at a body of work that stood
out on its own and i want to
have a set of skills that will transcend
above youtube and
all of that and so in order to do that
you have to do something a little
differently
and you have to basically put all your
energy
into each video and make them stand out
and make them
make them interesting make them
something that you're not doing for
views but you're doing because they were
challenging
for you i'm not sure if you said it just
joking around but you think you
mentioned that building a youtube
channel can
kind of make you go insane why do you
say that
building uh
building a youtube channel
i mean i think in order to
put yourself on camera to have talking
points to operate the camera
to operate the audio to
field questions to get rid of
you know to block out all of the bad
comments
to bring up and reinforce the good
i think you have to be a special kind of
sociopath
truthfully i mean it's a lot of work for
one person to do
it's definitely helpful if you have a
wife that's involved or a family member
or a friends or a group of other
youtubers that are like
in the mix with you i i definitely think
that's helpful but for one person a
one-man band to do it
it's a herculean effort um and
it normally means that you're cutting
out all
forms of like social life so
thank god for my wife she lets me just
she's
she believes in it she's trusting it so
she's letting me go you know
full speed at it but you know at the
extent of my own sanity sometimes of not
having a social life
and you know feeling like a little bit
of a prisoner
a prisoner of my own success you know do
you think um
views and social media likes equate
with happiness i think
yeah you know that's a slippery slope
when i first got into this
uh what i wanted the most was to
give people a sense of shock or wonder
in the videos to leave them with a
lasting impression
and i think it's inevitable that you end
up comparing yourselves you end up
comparing yourself to your last videos
and you sort of get
sucked into this game of working for the
views and panhandling for
views and comments it's it's just part
of the mix there's no way to separate it
as much as i try and as much as i want
to i have to like
spend an enormous amount of time kind of
brainwashing myself that like
that is not important even though it has
an enormous weight
it's it's tough do you think you would
have started
um a few years back if you had known not
just
the the pressure of putting out
something that your audience will like
and
top the last one but also your own
expectations
you know you know what's crazy is that
uh yeah i do kind of wish i started
earlier i think it would have been
easier for me i would have had more free
time i would have had a little bit more
energy that kind of thing
but if i look back in the last two years
of just my technical skills they have
ballooned in that short two years of
having the youtube channel
the the amount that i've learned and
packed in there
is exponential to the first two years
that i had
you know so putting yourself under
deadline and putting
yourself under public scrutiny and
putting up bodies of work to be judged
that is it's a whole process
of of whittling down your skills and and
really really
refining your talent and just
sharpening that blade so sure i wish i
would have started
years before but i also think that i
would have had
less to offer and i think that i might
not
have put so much into it as i am now
maybe that's something that
when you get older you start doing i
don't know
but do you think you would have um
actually gone for it knowing
how difficult it is and it is very
isolating and
people don't realize that about the job
i don't think i don't know that i would
i don't i think it's one of those things
where you kind of get sucked in
and and so when people look at the
channel and they look at the amount of
work that i put into certain videos
they're like wow you put so much time
and effort into that but to me that's
like the normal that's just like oh yeah
i'm putting up bodywork so it takes this
and that and
you just have to you have to invest you
got to do it and so
if i had known that from the start maybe
not maybe i would have said
you know what's an easier way to to make
my art and not have to
worry about rejection every time i
upload something i don't know
do you remember the days when a lot of
people turned their nose up
at putting content on youtube a lot of
times people
thought they're so funny yeah so the
whole youtube thing has
i mean i think what youtube started in
or 2006 or something like the first
youtube video went up
and then slowly like we got around like
oh no you can actually make
like they started monetizing it and
putting ads and you can actually build a
following
and make a living and then for like the
last
you know for like that first maybe 10
years
it was kind of like this stigmatized
thing of like oh if you can't make it as
an actor you could do parody videos on
youtube or like what does youtube know
but now when you look at it some of the
most
skillful you know camera operators or
like
uh storytellers are on youtube and they
have figured this out years ago and they
have built up this audience and now you
have
you want to know what sells movies it's
not the rock
it's not his acting skills it's his
ability to like
motivate followers i mean this guy every
time i look at his instagram he's got
another 10 million subscribers i don't
even know what he's at now i mean 150
million subscribers on instagram
so like motivating them to go see your
movie
fast and furious 19 or whatever it is
like that's real power
that is real like that is the future
that we're going down
and so how do you do that i mean and you
can definitely do that in youtube and
these youtube creators
they may have been laughed at years ago
when it was first starting out
but they are holding all the cards now
they
have everything and it all has to do
with
letting people in showing them what you
can do
being humble uh building a core audience
of people that will follow you anywhere
and they'll go watch your movie or
or go visit your body of work or your
your art or whatever it may be
i want to read a comment that someone
left on our channel and
it uses a dirty word which is uh the i
word
influencer and so that's a dirty word
in some circles it is so the the comment
and i'm paraphrasing is
the world doesn't need any more
influencers slash youtubers slash
filmmakers
what the world needs is more teachers
engineers social workers etc
what are your thoughts i mean so
youtubers are teachers and if you think
about it this way they're actually being
paid
what teachers should be paid so like the
whole university
scheme or like public education scheme
of what we have of how
we have people that should be regarded
as our highest esteemed
profession these are the people that are
that are teaching our children of what
to learn how to be
how to how to act in a public arena
and yet they're making 30 000 a year or
they're
they're making so little that they
they check out when they're doing their
work so they're not really good at what
they do
right or they're just not suited for the
job they're not passionate i mean we've
all had a teacher who's passionate
like my family is a line of teachers my
dad's a teacher my mom's a teacher my
aunt's a teacher my uncle's a teacher
so many teachers they're all passionate
about what they teach
and the best teachers i've had we're
always passionate about that as well and
so that really comes across and i think
you have youtubers who uh now not all
youtubers and not all
influencers but if you are genuinely
passionate about what you're talking
about that is going to
drive home much much
easier into your viewers heads
than someone that's just doing it for
money or for views or for
whatever reasons people do it for i mean
i do understand that
the their influencer does get a bad
rep and that's mostly because of
instagram i think yeah
the idea of like going to these exotic
places and
photographing you hanging out of a
helicopter door with your shoes on with
a pretty girl
and in reality that's not you know
that's
like maybe a hundredth of what that
experience actually was like it like
shies away from the whole
it's just that part definitely gets a
bad rep
for influencers but you know youtubers i
think
the ones that are like actually teaching
something i think they have
they know they know their worth they
know that it's they're not the same
as like a lifestyle instagram
vlogger yeah that's just trying to
flex all the time i don't know
what filmmaking tools do you use
consistently with every video
what filmmaking tools do i use with
every video
i mean you know i used to just use
uh i never used a tripe
i never used tripods i only just i was
the gimbal guy so i would use a camera
and a gimbal for everything
and now i'm starting to like revisit
that and now i'm using less
of a gimbal and more doing classical
composition
how can i hold the viewer's attention
with what is important in the scene and
you don't need a gimbal for that you
could just rely
on that actual composition of the shot
so
i think i mean this is kind of a weird
answer but i think story
is more of what i'm using instead of
like the flashy transitions or
cinematography it's more of like how do
i get back to just story
what do i need to tell them as little as
i have to tell them
at that moment so i can keep dangling
that carrot and they can keep
watching and try to figure it out those
are the kinds of things that i'm into
now
is that what you asked i don't know if
that was you asked me what kind of stuff
do i bring on every shoot
uh tools but what tools then you then
you talked about story and
and how that's important so sometimes i
think story just i think story trumps
everything i think you can have
the fanciest camera you can have the
fanciest lens you can have
a real expensive light you can have
another expensive light
you can do all of this with the sun and
a simple bounce
and a camera and a tripod and if your
story is good
and your audio is clean i think audio
clean audio is probably
number two maybe number one actually
um those are the tools that you need
yeah i don't really
feel like i'm good at story though
that's the weird thing i feel like every
episode is
uh a challenge and it's a work in
progress
you know um story is uh
mercurial it's constant you can never
get a grasp on it the moment you think
that you have figured it out
it becomes stale and you're no longer
interested in it so you have to like
figure out another
way to do it um so for me the whole
channel
i mean if you guys look at each episode
there i try to do something a little bit
different like i don't find two episodes
are the same
like i'll get good at something i'll
figure out the story the storytelling of
like the typical vlog i'll try to mimic
that as much as i can
and then and then at the end of it if if
i feel like
oh yeah i got a handle on that then it i
change it to something else
and try to learn something new so
i don't know i i'm in a constant state
of feeling like i'm not nailing story at
all
but knowing the reverence and knowing
how important it is
to keep keep your audience engaged but
also to keep me
engaged as a creator when you wanted to
write was it screenplays or
novels um screenplays is what
yeah screenplays what i started like who
who were some of your so like you know
reading all like the sid
fields and blake snyder books save the
cat
and you know hero's journey and all that
stuff so i think
um i don't know i think mark the the
duploss brothers were like an
inspiration at the time
also um adam sandler
um vince vaughn all those guys that
seemed to have a handle on
just writing their own content and
and making it happen those are huge
inspirations for me um i think that's
probably where i got
tripped up with trying to be the actor
thing like oh i have to be an actor too
and then i can give my story and like
write my stories
um and it seems like that's not actually
true
so you had no plans to stay in arizona
no
oh i say no i i just went there for
college i went there to
get away for a few years and then uh
came back to los angeles and
i got my first agent and
then was fired from that agent and then
got another agent
and i think that's the trick i think
once they fire you once
that like messes with your brain you're
like now i got an axe to grind now i
gotta figure this out
um so yeah and that was back when i was
yeah i was like 23 at the time then i
stopped i completely gave up acting when
i was 31
32 so almost 10 years of just going
going after it not getting anywhere
when you talked about your uncle and the
sense of freedom that he had with the
ebay business
do you feel that i know it's a lot to
have a video ready and i know there's a
lot of pressure on that and
pleasing the audience but is there do
you see some
hints of that going thinking back to
when you were 16 working at his
warehouse or wherever that was
you know my uncle just had a really good
work ethic
of
of i don't know
actually okay
let's see here how does that link to
i see that in you so that's i mean i
don't just from seeing just a few
videos and interviews and things like
that i see some kind of work ethic that
doesn't seem
like normal i don't so actually i think
it's hard it's not for my uncle
um the work ethic
so i know where it came from uh
the work ethic is for me it's
it's not about the building subscriber
base or building
the views it's about the body of work
right to be an artist
to like at the end of 10 years have an
album of work that you're really really
proud of
and so for me that was an acting coach
who i studied with for
the bulk of that 10 years a lady named
sharon chattan who's in venice beach and
she's still
still teaching still doing it and she
was the one that actually
that i found when i was like 23 or 24
that made me feel like an artist
and put the reverence in to the process
of of acting and it wasn't just acting
but it was a reference to stories so
like
the choices that you could make as an
actor may be right for the scene or may
get you the part or
but they might not serve the story so is
that the right choice so like the
reverence for
story and like and i don't know i guess
just the reference for being an artist
and putting up a body of work that
you're really proud of and
and just keep going keep grinding away
yeah that for sure sharon chattan 100
and going back to the teachers that have
passion for what they do
she's 100 percent that yeah she is uh
fully passionate about everything that
she does
um she's like the hardcore new york
strasbourg method acting coach and like
on a weekly basis someone would leave
her cr her class crying
and you know it's like barry you ever
watch barry
i haven't okay but i've been wrong it's
exactly it's
uh what's the guy's name winkler oh oh
henry winkler yeah it's henry winkler's
character to a t
all obsessed the story like those people
actually exist that was my that was my
acting coach
and and she's 100 right you know you
have to be you have to have that
reverence for like story and work
otherwise you're just another
influencer i guess oh get it get that
out
okay the i word
should a beginning youtuber aim to make
the best videos
you know there's so many to can quote
compete with and it's very intimidating
or try another approach i think a
beginning youtuber should try
to just be as genuine and as
grounded as they can be and it sounds
simple but
those are the types of videos that
really respond i mean
as an audience you have this uncanny
ability to sniff out when someone's not
being
them their authentic self and
one of the things that i always really
appreciate was when someone was
authentic enough to show us a glimpse of
their life
the good stuff but also like the not so
good stuff right
to be on the same level as us so that
you leave
feeling like wow i actually know that
person like i've been there i've
experienced those things um i think i
think that's actually a trait it's like
it's something you have to work on when
i first
started if you watch that very first
video that i uploaded
you see a lot of flexing it's a lot of
like i'm
validating myself therefore you must
watch me
and i can't tell like that makes me
cringe now because it should
just be the work or the message or
whatever it is that you're trying to
convey
that is the validation right like what
you're trying to teach
sh is validating if it's good it'll
validate you don't have to be like oh
look at all these accolades
i have and this is why i'm worthy of
your time none of that
it's just the body of work should be
enough to validate
um so if you compare like my later
videos
you definitely see a change of me trying
to do
implement more of like the
grounded approach of like no more
flexing instead i do a reverse flex
which is like i like this is what i'm
really terrible at you know i mean
and show and really like uh
show the cracks show the flaws i'm i'm
really into that right now
so well i think you grow into the work
too like maybe on and i'm
just speaking for myself but you kind of
have a different reason when you started
then when you start continuing because
it's not an easy thing so usually that
first reason
doesn't work anymore yeah i mean there's
definitely something that's trying to be
satiated with
doing the youtube videos um i mean i i
recently left my
cnbc job so now i'm doing youtube full
time but
i still seem to be putting out just as
many videos so it's kind of weird
but there's something in there that i'm
in addition to
obviously making a living doing it
there's something in there that i'm
trying to
unearth trying to figure out and uh it's
fair to say that i don't actually know
what that is
there's something though maybe maybe one
day i will know maybe i won't know i
don't know
how many videos are you working on at a
time and do you finish
everything you start no uh that's
actually the downfall
um one of my one of my downfalls
uh if i were to give advice to someone
starting youtube
it would be work at one video work on
one video at a time
and then don't even start the next one
until that one is finished
unfortunately i don't follow that i i
have like four videos that i'm
trying to get out right now i'm
currently backlogged on them and
trying to finish him up and i wish to
god that i didn't have
that work ethic where i could just be
like it's done it's finished and move on
to the next
because it would probably let me pump
out videos quicker
but uh each one is just as important so
it makes it harder i think if i do start
to switch over to one video at a time
you will see more videos on a consistent
basis but there are a ton of videos that
i've shot that
simply have not seen the light of day
and too much time has passed now that
i don't feel like they're worth my time
to pursue to finish
uh because they're not they're no longer
relevant or the
you know the yes too much time has gone
by
kind of a downer topic for me well i
think that's common for a lot of artists
to start things
and kind of leave them i hope so i hope
it's not just me
yeah i think writers feels like like a
man on a on an island you know
if you could travel back and change one
thing
if you had a time machine yeah what
would that be
i do have a time machine computer turn
on the time machine
time machine is on let's cut to a wide
shot
oh all right computer turn off time
machine
hello anytime now computer turn off time
there we go all right that's the time
machine that's all it does
it just lights up all right so if i had
a time machine if i go back and change
one thing what would it be
um
i don't know that i don't know that i
would because that's
i've had a lot of time thinking about
this question i've thought about this
for months because i built a time
machine art project at burning man
and that was the question that i wanted
everyone else to ask
right like what is this fantasy of time
travel why is it that we
fantasize about seeing into the future
and
preventing certain catastrophes or
maybe planning out some sort of
win investment or whatever like
seeing into the future and just scoring
big
or looking back in the past and changing
some of these
hard grievances that you know these
memories that have like weighed down on
us right
those things you know uh those are the
things that shape you
so those the past trauma
it kind of makes you who you are so if
you were to take away those things would
you still be you i don't know that's
that's a larger question they ask
um but i the interesting thing is that i
did leave
uh inside the time machine art project
that we built we left little pieces of
paper
for people to write down where we asked
this question so we had about 200
responses
and it was incredible i mean the amount
of responses that we got that were
like people for the most part you know
they wanted to spend more time they wish
they spent more time with their kids
or they wish they didn't um
they wish they spoke to their father uh
and buried the hatchet before he got
sick
right so like all like they had all
these
these things that were so valuable and
so meaningful and important
none of them were oh i wish i invested
in
apple in 1980 you know like it was all
relationships and personal stuff so um i
don't know if you've seen
that like the dying wishes of people
with
you know cancer whatever on their on
their deathbed and they're
living back their regrets and whatever
almost all of their answers
are uh the same and it's all i wish i
spent more time with my family wish i
hadn't worked so hard
wish i'd you know i mean it's all
personal relationships
i think that's the same thing that's
probably my answer
how did you feel when people left these
responses for you like
were you sort of overwhelmed that they
trusted the process enough or
i mean they didn't i mean it was a sense
of autonomy so these people were leaving
their
answers without any other information so
i i felt like
or there's a sense of privacy so they
were they
no one was going to judge them so they
were incredibly
private with their responses and i felt
i felt really lucky in fact
at first i wanted to include their
responses or read them off
in my my video that i did about it but
then i felt like that might have been a
betrayal
so i kept them for myself i still have
them and i don't know if i'll make
something from them one day
or you know i read them from time to
time
but i mean there's some powerful stuff
in there um
because it's on paper right so there's
no wi-fi there's no way anybody can come
and
hack in and see the answers so yeah you
just it was a it was a little mailed
dropbox so you know it was great i mean
there's also a couple of
uh dick pics in there as well oh that's
great dick drawings yeah
good one probably only one person that
did it and he didn't
numerous times just two don't there's
like three or four i was like wow
and he got better at each one you know
hey you got a bunch of artists there
they're bored you know i still kept
those those are great
how do you push your art to the next
level yeah i think
every time you do something you have to
attempt something new
and i yeah that's i try to do that in
every single video
if i don't feel like i'm on the brink of
failure
every time i'm doing something wrong
it's too kind i actually i get
bored if i do something repetitive so i
try to like
i just find a new way to do it um
i think that's probably why it takes so
long for me to get out videos
is because it's not really a cookie
cutter thing for me it's all about
refining that art
and pushing it even further
i think you had said and this was maybe
when you were at the um
the sony camp yeah i think this was you
who said that
if you if you're not excited by what
you're making
that your audience won't either and and
that don't try to like pander to the
audience
maybe i mean it sounds like something
okay was that on my video or was it
someone else's
no there we watched several and by the
way it looked really cool
to go to that oh my god it was so much
fun
yeah sony put on such a hit show for
everybody i mean it was so great
especially just being around all the
other content creators and
feeling that camaraderie of like hey
we're all in the mix
like if so that was probably one of the
healthiest things that
a content creator can do for their
psyche is being around other content
creators who are going through the same
stuff
and you really learn that you we're all
on the same side there's no competition
of like who's doing better than who
it's like we're on the same team that
was super helpful
uh but going back to your question um
yeah i i do genuinely feel that if i'm
not
invested if i'm not excited by what i'm
making
how am i supposed to get someone else
excited about it
i've literally stopped episodes in the
middle of the episode
and i'm like i don't want to do this and
i stop i'm like i'm going to stop
throwing good money after bed
because i'm no longer excited about this
it's me selling a product or it's me
uh doing something for views like i was
just working on an iphone 11 video
i had strapped it to a drone and i was
going to fly it
and show the world what iphone 11's new
processor does for video in the dynamic
range and this is what a glimpse of
next year's drones will look like and
about halfway through i was like
i don't even like apple why would i like
try to prop up iphone 11 sales at all
like why because the video is going to
do well i'm like i'm out i'm out
so i stopped that video will never see
the light of day
well i mean from an outsider's
perspective seeing that sony camp
it was great to kind of like live
vicariously there and and
what's interesting is maybe this has
just been my experience but
with acting i think there's way more
competition i've seen in the youtube
space
people seem pretty satisfied with where
they're at in terms of
there's not as much maybe it's all below
the surface but when you meet people
it's not that weird acting or actor sort
of competition
yeah that was one thing that i was used
to having that
kind of edge on your shoulder with the
actor thing
you know like because in the acting
world if one person's
one person's success meant everyone
else's
failure like they they were getting cast
repeatedly
so that role is not available for you
but in the youtube space that has
nothing to do with it at all
if somebody's video does well it
actually may
make your channel more successful
because it'll pave the way for you to
say oh that's working
that's something i can do or you know
maybe maybe i'll try that and
it's different it's it's a totally
different dynamic for sure
um when i first came into the youtube
space it felt
i felt more camaraderie especially when
i did a good video
i was expecting people to be upset or
jealous but it was the opposite they
reached out to me they were
genuinely happy for my success they were
like wow you really
you you knocked it out of the park or
wow another banger or
you know whatever it was and they would
have some questions or whatever but
genuinely happy for my success and that
was very refreshing
what do you think that is i've seen the
same you know on a smaller scale
and i i've noticed that there doesn't
seem to be that that like edge
i think it's inherent of putting up
bodies of work
and putting yourself out there and
saying and putting your name
on it and then being you know sending it
up
to the gods and whether it's going to be
rejected
whether you're going to be torn apart i
think it takes a certain humility
to do that um
and so i feel like you know we're all in
this together is the kind of the
mentality of like wow you put up a body
of work like you did it
wow you know good for you um and if it's
a success then it's like
awesome we know how hard it is we know
how difficult it is to
to have a video go viral like
man you deserve it it's not the same as
like the
the actor thing because there's no
yet that competition is just not really
there
one person's success does not mean
everyone else is failure
or lack of success it just means their
success
when you were at the sony camp did you
did you feel validated like wow this is
i'm here because
of my work i'm here because i'm
really like painstakingly looking at
what i'm doing and making sure that
if it's my it was an interesting dynamic
because
it was the first time that i had been
anywhere
where i knew all the people there but i
hadn't
met them right so i knew everyone's name
i knew where they were from i knew what
their schtick was i knew what
the cameras they use i knew personal
things about them
and i and then being like face to face
i'm like oh hey
oh i'm josh by the way that was like
that was a weird
dynamic but um it taught me that
um you know as the as the creator it's
kind of a one-way
uh relationship that you're crafting
with the audience so like
they're getting to know you they're the
more they see
you on screen the more they get to know
you the more they fall in love with you
the more they
whatever it is right but yet you don't
know anything about them and so it's
it's a it's definitely something to be
mindful of
um and so i was very aware of that at
the sony event
where i was like wow i i feel like i
know all these people but
but if they don't watch my channel they
have no idea who i am you know
so it was weird
art is something to live for if you find
yourself comfortable enough
you make enough money and you live in
the state of finding inspiration
and creation and that is my definition
of making it
yeah was that always your definition
uh no
my first you know when i was 18 19
first moving out here i had one of those
vision boards remember those were like
the hit
and i had a vision board and it had like
you know
a bentley on it and it had an amex black
and it had like a brittling
watch and you know whatever and it had
bikini girls like it was so
so detached from like reality of like
what is
what is actually worth living for is it
things like
things that validate you i don't know if
that's true if you look at all the rich
people that are very miserable in life
they would argue that's just their very
existence
that's not true i think the people that
are
that are happiest in life have a sense
of purpose they have a sense of value
normally it's earned value so there are
rich people that have earned value and
they
like bill gates he's probably one of the
happiest wealthy
wealthiest people on the planet right
now and look at him he's like
totally has all this value he's giving
back he's making toilets that like will
work in
india that are they run on nothing
like solar powered toilets or something
you're talking that guy is has nailed it
right
so like we all can't be bill gates but
maybe we can all have that sense of
value and so for me
it was like you know creating art
creating something if it's maybe just a
poem or
a snapshot or something that gives you a
little bit of inspiration
if it if it affects you if it's
something that you remember for years
and you're like wow that really inspired
me or like
that got me out of a slump that's
that's something to live for that's
amazing i think i heard steve wozniak
say that he just really wanted to make
cool stuff all the time
that was his goal and he was in a
position of course to to do that but
that
prompted you know that you could see
that behind
what they created and it continued even
after
i feel like people like steve wozniak
who have that mentality
they don't stop like they just kee like
they're
so the moment for me was
i you know as an actor you always say i
want to make it right i want to
i want to make it and what does that
mean oh it means like you got all the
roles you got money in the bank you got
a house paid off
you got a vacation home you got nice
family and your kids are going to
college
it normally just means success and money
right
and then i was like and then what
like so if i'm envisioning this i make
it and then what
then i just stop i just stop like if
that
if my definition of making it is just
things
and money eventually i'm going to get
that
and eventually i'm not going to know
what to do with my time so that can't be
the goal
the goal has to be something a little
bit loftier than that it has to be
something that
it's uh it's dependent on
uh i don't know it's it's something that
you just keep doing
right so like inspiring people that
would that's a goal
because that that has no end you just
keep doing that till the day you die
there's no
so for making it for me stopped becoming
monetary incentives and it became
uh let's just blow people's mind
let's that's yeah let's do that and just
keep doing that and keep doing that how
do i how do i do that
you know so that's what it is for me
and that mental challenge too that comes
from
well you know what it was uh
making it change forms
and instead of making it it was
making it right the process of
making it became make art now
um that mental challenge i think
i have to deal with every day of what am
i gonna make today
what's gonna be new what's gonna be
different what's gonna what's gonna blow
my mind because if it blows my mind then
there's a good chance it might blow your
mind too
do you go to the getty do you do like
cultural things in l.a i've gone to the
getty several times
uh both villas and
gone to lakma um i think what
what really uh what i enjoy the most
what inspires me the most
is attempting something i've never done
before
it's challenging and then once i get
kind of once i crack the code there's
normally like three
things that you need to learn to like
start getting good results
there's only it's it's funny it's only
like three things like once you know the
code those three things
you can get some pretty good results
right and so for me it's always like
trying set
that new thing figuring out those three
things and then looking at that footage
and
and being like wow holy crap i did like
that's how they do it
oh my god that nobody tells you that
like totally reverse engineering
it that's what gets me going and uh i
feel the most inspired after that so
it'll be like a night
shooting downtown la middle of the
middle of like you know two in the
morning or something like that
no one's up and i'm rolling around on my
one wheel
filming skyscrapers and my mind's
totally blown and i'm
i i'm so excited that i can't go to
sleep you know
yeah that's sorry last question just
have you ever had anything risky happen
what do you mean by risky well i mean
you're with camera equipment
people are probably drawn to you like
what are you doing are you an actor are
you a host i
feel yeah i have this uh
i feel like every shoot is kind of risky
like
um i've hurt myself a couple of times
you know riding around on a one wheel
with camera equipment in traffic
like that's risky like though normal
people
shouldn't take those risks i'm totally
fine
and comfortable taking those risks but i
also acknowledge that
if that's the requirement to be seen on
youtube
that's a very risky profession
so uh but i feel like i've always been
the kind of personality to
try to get my hair blown back you know
um
so it it definitely satiates some part
of adventure in me